and more questions tonight on what led
up to a deadly shooting at a birthday
party that left a Legacy High School
student dead thank you for joining us at
11 o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftis 17 year old Omarion
Wilson's family speaking out exclusively
to eight news now about what happened
and what type of person he was Madison
Kimbrough live in studio tonight Madison
has more yeah Marion's family welcomed
us at their family balloon release
tonight I got to speak to those closest
to the 17 year old as about a hundred
people were there including Metro Police
take a look
this is just a
sad day for me
because my baby is gone and I'm gonna
miss him Georgia Wiggins is talking
about her grandson's 17-year-old amarion
Wilson he was shot and killed inside the
Platinum Hotel at a friend's birthday
party over the weekend he just called me
crying saying like Mario's shot Jeremiah
is his uncle sharing exclusively with 8
news now how he got the news that his
nephew was hurt seen that call come
through she told me
I did 100 on the freeway to get there
his friends and family coming together
Monday for a balloon release to honor
the teenager who was a senior at Legacy
High School he made me very proud and
more more importantly he made his mother
proud
[Applause]
golden black balloons filled the air the
colors his family says he planned to
wear to his prom on Saturday Omarion a
student athlete described as outgoing
and competitive playing basketball
football boxing no matter what it was he
always going at it you feel me he always
tried his best at what he wanted to do
but now his friends and family left
remembering what was after Saturday's
tragedy leaves them forever changed he
was gonna go to college go play ball we
just go graduate together they took my
childhood best friend
now Metro Police are still looking for
the suspect last described on Saturday
as a black male in dark clothing live in
studio Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now